say good morning to Ross Tucker from NBC
Sports Network also work in Westwood one
radio so I'm on the sidelines for the
Eagles game against the Falcons and then
he was there for the Jags and the
Steelers Ross good morning thanks for
joining us which game do you want to
start with what what game was more
interesting to you Dan you know I mean
I'm seeing you on Saturday Rodney and
Dungy both have hats on not you and I
was on the sideline it was legitimately
cold so the combination of you not
wearing a hat even though was
legitimately really cold and the the
ball cannon incident went in like broke
your glasses or hit your you're a lot
tougher than people give you credit for
I appreciate that Ross hashtag warrior
the the Eagles Falcons game you know I I
like the Eagles in this game because I
thought they were more than just Carson
Wentz but what did you see out of this
game as you know Philadelphia's gonna
welcome Minnesota in the the difference
in the Falcons and the Vikings for this
Eagles team is what yeah well I think
the Vikings are much better up front
both sides the ball than the Falcons
were you're talking with some of the
players and the coaches on the field
before that sounds Eagles game they knew
the deal I mean the Eagles know they got
two first-team all-pro offensive lineman
and Kelsey and Lane Johnson I think
they're right guard Brandon Brooks might
be the best of the bunch plus then that
D line was Fletcher Cox Brandon Graham
they know that Nick Foles is not as good
as Matt Ryan even though I thought foals
actually played pretty decently
especially in the second half but they
knew they needed to win the game upfront
and that's exactly what they did and
that's exactly what they'll try to do
against the Vikings it just it will not
be as easy because the Vikings are
really good up front both sides of the
ball as well but that'll be the recipe
for the Eagles I guess the good news is
they're not playing us a quarterback
that's as good as Matt Ryan but I think
Keenum definitely has the edge over
foals and silly-- it feels like we're
grading these quarterbacks on a
different curve you know Brady is in his
own classroom here Case Keenum is
probably next it feels like foals and
bortles
we grade them that they had a good game
if they didn't make any mistakes here
whereas we're asking Brady to win games
Case Keenum to make a couple of plays
and then you have fools and in Blake
bortles do you see it that way I think
that's a very fair way to look at it
either way I'm thrilled for bortles I
mean I can't remember a quarterback
that's taken as much crap as she has and
he's handled it so well I'm really glad
he played so well yesterday I would say
this though with both holes and bortles
not only did they not turn it over Dan
but both of them made enough third down
conversions to lean on their defense to
lean on the running game to get the win
so we've seen a bunch of games recently
the last two games for both those guys
they were horrendous I mean you know I
they gave their team no chance to win
bortles for about three weeks I don't
know how they beat the bills Falls the
last two times out the way this guys
played this weekend if they could play
that way this weekend again they at
least give their team's a chance to win
those games you end up doing the Eagles
game and then you have to drive over to
the Pittsburgh game the following day
and tell people who who was your partner
in the car well it was hilarious because
Westar 1 said hey you can do both games
but can you give 24 celje drives our
ride and I said are you kidding me so
you have to understand Dan like my
junior high school was Vasilis rookie
year so his six years where he was the
best left tackle on the biggest
three-time first-team all-pro that was
my glory days high school in college as
a fan so he was like he was an idol I
mean we got smaller shoulder pads for
him we had to hair come out of the back
of our helmet because they him he was
the dude so to be in a car with him for
five hours and that would be like I
don't know you being a car with like
Pete Maravich for five hours driving
across the entire state it was it was a
thrill with me for me it being a
Pennsylvania kid to do the Eagles and
Steelers game was awesome enough but
then to drive five hours with one of my
one of my idols was it was it was
incredible just to hear him tell stories
about going as Bruce
and Derrick Thomas and I mean he's
hilarious he said you could take a pill
and play five more years you would he's
one of those guys who didn't play long
enough but I I said you know people
forget how great he was I don't know if
he'll get into the Hall of Fame if he
played a couple more years he probably
would but he's up there with Anthony
Munoz as two of the greatest left
tackles I've ever ever saw yeah he's a
finalist this year again I think Terrell
Davis Dan getting in last year yeah
really helps because Tony's basically
the old-line version of Terrell Davis
the other difference though is that
thrill Davis won through Super Bowls and
had historic postseason runs and
facility played for the Jags I think I
think is interesting I'd love to hear
you guys talk about some point does the
Jags winning like this you know the
Jackie AFC champs you came more
conversation about the Jacksonville
Jaguars more conversation about Tony
Bocelli I just wonder how much that
matters when they get into a room
because it seemed to me like that was
part of the reason why Ricky Jackson
when the Saints won the Super Bowl that
was part of the reason why Ricky Jackson
kind of elected that year it seems like
when your team the team you played for
goes on a run it almost helps your Hall
of Fame candidacy you know that's a
great point and something to keep an eye
on we're talking to Ross Tucker Westwood
one analyst and he's got the Minnesota
Vikings and the Eagles that'll be Sunday
on Westwood One you were in Pittsburgh
explain to me what exactly when did you
realize Pittsburgh was in trouble the
first drive I thought wow because they
came out really flat maybe that's what
happens man when you're starting safety
is talking about the Patriots your
running back tweets night before the
game
we got back-to-back rematches I mean I
just talked to Barry Church this morning
and talked to some of the Jags before
the game they were really really
offended I mean they they 1:30 to 9 in
Pittsburgh earlier in the year and the
skewers are acting like they didn't have
to play the game and they came out
punched him in the mouth that first
drive I thought oh boy we might have a
ball game and then they get a couple
three and out they get a pick five miles
jack
it's 21-nothing and that's what I really
knew this was going to be an awesome
game because he knew that Bend and the
Antonio Brown lady I felt you knew they
would mount a comeback it's almost like
you know the NBA that they're always
going to make a run you knew this you
was gonna make a run and the Jag did
just enough to be able to overcome am i
I can't believe that the Jacksonville
Jaguars scored 45 point I know a lot of
people are pointing to a couple of the
forces shorts I robbed this burger in
the Steelers and I get it but they gave
up 45 points and I know one was a you
know a fumble return for touchdown but
45 and they scored 42 yeah I guess maybe
the best in the NFL yeah and there's
stuff that's going on with the Steelers
that that you can't be that good and and
I was even talking about this in the
first hour can you remember a team that
had a Hall of Fame quarterback and
potential Hall of Famers at wide
receiver and running back on the same
team and they have nothing to show for
it and they may not have anything to
show for it when it's all said and done
something's missing here no I'll take it
a step further did they also have the
best offensive line in the NFL it's
either them or the Saints but I'll take
the Steelers offensive line so you got
the best running back the best wide
receiver you mentioned what you said
about Rob this burger here's what's
really crazy I went through this last
night man because you mentioned the
Steelers have nothing to show for it the
last few years even though they've had
that group by my count if you went man
for man I think three guys for the
Patriots definitely start for the
Steelers Brady grunt and Devin McCourty
and I think you'd probably take this the
Patriots corners Butler and Gilmore over
Joe Hayden and Artie burns but that's
not like a no-brainer I think maybe five
or six Patriots would even start for the
Pittsburgh Steelers yet the Patriots are
probably going to win I have a great
chance at least to win their third Super
Bowl in the last four years and the
Steelers haven't been able to even get
to one even though they have much better
personnel across the board
I'll leave the audience with this
because we of course cover the serious
stories the hard-hitting story
would you leave us with the Tom Brady
beer-chugging story since you were a
team a team is absolutely it was back in
oh six training camp I the guy is
absolutely a madman crazy intense about
everything he does it was oh six
training camp a couple of rookie linemen
going against Brady and I was going to
put my money on the rookie old linemen
because I thought you know crazy kind of
a pretty boy whatever and the older guys
on the team looked at me because my
second year in New England I never seen
Brady chug a beer they looked at me and
they were like uh uh Brady is the best
chugger I've ever seen in my life
he destroyed them he slammed down the
plastic cup I think broke it and had an
intensity like it was more important
than the Super Bowl everything that guy
does in life stand he's a complete
psycho about which i think is why I used
this good safe travels they're wrong
it's good to talk to you buddy and
thanks for saying they're great soon
yeah all right
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]